Rather than be an oxidative, doesn't this look more like an antioxidant, can there be a place for antioxidants and cancer protocols?
Yes, there can be a place for antioxidants and cancer protocols.
And not everybody agrees with me that you shouldn't be generically just doing, you know, not doing antioxidants.
It's just the more I've learned, the more I've studied and the more experience that I've had.
So for 9 out of 10 people that we test, do not test well with antioxidants.
It's literally 10% of my patient base that have ever come to me, have we, that have cancer that we've put them on a little diet.
I don't think anybody's tested for NAD, that your antioxidant, the negative of nitric oxide stimulation is not antioxidant versus pro oxidative therapy.
It's that it stimulates veg F production. So that's vascular endothelium growth factor.
So I'd say if a person theoretically if a person has a blood cancer, a leukemia, then I don't see a problem with the NAD.
If you have a hard cancer, we need a, you know, a tumor type cancer.
Then again, there's no way I would use nitric oxide stimulators because that isn't going to increase the vascularization of that tumor and increase the survival factor of that tumor.
So I have no idea why that clinic is doing that. I have no idea why the clinic is just standardly using glutathione lever.
That's just my tank. You can disagree with me, think people can disagree with me. That's just my understanding.
I have no idea why the clinic is just standardly using glutathione lever.